No more fucking yelp. I don't know what it's using in this shit in the water.
I was like, how are you working?
You know, I was like, this is a spark.
I showed him air.
Air profile and everything.
And then I was like, why aren't you working?
He said, oh, I get needs to be out.
I was like, stop that shit.
I was like, this is not work.
So I first started, and I was losing a lot of money doing that.
I was like, this is way better.
You said I'd tell your page out there.
You didn't get traction to your page.
It's so trim it is, it is where it's at.
I'm trying to get them on board with you.
I just spoke to him for like two weeks ago.
And I told him to have questions, and I'll show you the proof of the leads we get,
and the amount that I have been growing because of, because of spark.